hang the rapists the demonstrators
chanted as the four men arrived in court
to hear their sentence activists say
they believe the death penalty will act
as a deterrent to others many here
including top politicians believe
justice has been served semaj gay this
sentence will give justice to that girl
and her family the judge has set an
example to such anti-social elements by
saying that if someone commit such a
crime then this is the only punishment
for it and the others the four men were
found guilty of luring the victim onto a
bus and raping her repeatedly the
attackers tortured her with a metal bar
causing injuries that led to her death
the death penalty is rare in India but
the uproar sparked by the case spurred
the government to introduce the
possibility of its use for rape cases
that lead to death some doubt it'll work
as a deterrent the men's defense lawyer
laid out his position in no unclear
terms
I got a possible if by hanging the
rapists rape comes to a stop we will not
appeal to the High Court but if a rape
happens within two months then all the
talk about giving a message is wrong and
unjust got about nine thousand eight the
four men can appeal their case all the
way to the Supreme Court lawyers say
that process could take years